Can you see the right for cancer cause an increase in inflammation while it works to fight the cancer?
That is a good question.
I'm going to call up this tab real quick because you're putting it across your skin.
So can you see the right cause for cancer increase inflammation while it works to fight the cancer?
Yes, it can. So using the right was using frequency, technology, light waves to stimulate the body to fight this cancer.
What part of the body is fighting cancer? It's your immune system.
And your immune system does so by creating an acute inflammatory response. That's what your immune system does.
So while I thought inflammation is bad, yes, chronic inflammation is bad.
That's a chronic inflammatory response with chronic cytokine up regulation.
But you want an acute inflammatory response at the site of a cancer to kill the cancer.
Just like you want an acute inflammatory response when you have an acute bacterial infection or viral infection.
So it's not uncommon when a person is using a rifle and it's programmed correctly for that person's cancer that around that cancer there can be inflammation.
If there's inflammation elsewhere in the body, then that's an issue.
You do want to look for possible antibodies. You want to look for possible autoimmune issues.
But if there's just inflammation at the cancer, then that can be a good, good thing.
I have a post on my website where I think a video is contained on a tube where I talk about cancer, good pain versus bad pain.
Because a person when you're fighting cancer, whether you're using a rifle or proper nutrition to fight cancer and you have an inflammatory response,
pain or where that cancer is in your body, that increase inflammation could increase pain because it's going to occupy space.
So look at that good pain, bad pain video on our website.
Do symptoms seem to fluctuate when you are early on and using the right using between better and worse?
Yes, and that is a better sign if the symptoms are fluctuated because your immune response isn't just constant.
It will be a hyperimmune response, killing things that will die off and a hyperimmune response, killing things that die off.
It's not uncommon also to get a pseudo enlargement of a tumor when you're properly killing it as well.
It even on an MRI CT scan or a PET scan, it can look like it's an increased size because of the inflammation that's going on around the cancer, killing the cancer.
So be aware of that as well.